you know what i mean yeah yeah yeah
so okay so you're in new zealand you're
an engineer by trade
you're doing welding you're doing all
kinds of crazy work yeah and
on the side you're wrestling you're
wrestling doing wrestling gigs are you
making any money doing wrestling back
then
back then if you if i told you why you
were in new zealand were you making it
yeah
when i tell you i was making three
pounds
at two pounds or three pound a match if
you know what pound is those days
that's a pound was equal to two dollars
wow they make two that's a match yeah
and a wage at that time
would be a good wage would be about 15
pounds or
a week a wage that's that's for a
um not a professional but that's for an
average worker
was 10 to 15 pounds a week wow
by accident you kind of like fell into
this this was never like a dream
for you no no the next door neighbor and
then i went into that
hangout and that's you know so when did
you develop that whole
that whole moniker the whole whoa with
the no that's what
that came later that that came many many
moons later
we left home in 1997.
why did you yeah go back go back let's
go back we mainly had europeans
wrestlers from um
from europe and uh england when they
come over
we we actually ran three times a week or
twice a week three times a week
and a guy would come over for for say um
two months three months and that and
that's when we get most our work
and in 68 i started going to australia
the american promoter from atlanta
a well-known promoter who
who got um ted turner to put
the wrestling up on the um satellite on
tbs
or he was over in new zealand and that
was wcw
he was over in australia i'm sorry and
he come over there
in 65 and open up australia
that's when that's when the um vietnam
war was on
and all the uh troops were coming down
to australia
for r r rest and recreation
and he was there he opened up in
australia he bought out the
the roller derby and then bought a whole
american crew in
and started running and i'd go over
there and work work against the
americans
and that uh um maybe three times a year
go over there for
a month or three weeks and work against
americans
now when ted turner was
he was basically syndicating
wrestling shows across the world and
in lots of different countries yeah but
it started with the us right yeah but he
didn't
he didn't start the satellite didn't go
up to
uh to 76 i think you know the um
yeah it was called wtbs it was called
wtbs yeah
wtbs and then he dropped the w off it
and just tbs and what was the wrestling
program called it was w
it was world championship wrestling
that's what ted turner's
was called yeah ted turner well that was
jim barnett's company
okay jim barnett the australian promoter
actually owned part of florida
championship wrestling he owned
a part of a lot of companies around the
states but he was on
in atlanta he had wcw okay
and that and then later on in life you
know when
when um all the small territories went
out and vince was the only one
and that's when ted turner bought ted
turner bought
nwa and it changed from nwa to wcw
oh okay the name and that and that's
when they had the monday night wars
in the 90s but anyway we're going back
to the 60s right
right we jumped well ahead here [ __ ]
anyhow so i met a lot of americans and
that and andre came over to our country
too
in 69 under the giant yeah so butcher me
worked against
butch my partner and myself we partnered
up
in 66 you know locally and that
we never started touring overseas until
you know
the to the middle east not the middle
east
to the east singapore and and up in
bangkok and that
till 68 andre came over to new zealand
in 69 and butchered me worked with him
for a whole month around the country
really
yes holy [ __ ] what was that like oh
andre was only
two 350 then you're 350 360
and that and with a big a throw he looks
skinny
you know what i mean well six foot seven
foot two with a big afro
and only three three fifty you know i
mean
that's incredible you spent a whole
month with him so
that's how when i first met andre in
that and of course too i met
the big names like killer kowalski he
was the biggest
one of the biggest names in the heels in
the in the world at the time
yeah who who was main event of what
madison square
gardens in the 60s and in the 70s he was
the male he
he was the main bad guy and he's the guy
that actually got australia going
for jim barnett you know
our business is cowboys and indians yeah
and that and um
he was the the guy that they bought in
and he actually popped australia
and got it up going you know for for jim
barnett
wow and uh so when i come over in 72
butcher me came over to um north america
for the first time
and what what why did you guys come for
the first time what was the reason well
you know hollywood was
if you want to be a star in in movies
and television and that
you go to hollywood if you want all the
wrestling magazines you know we
we didn't get uh a wrestling show to 76
in new zealand
on television and that so we we got
wrestling magazines
in the 60s and that and you know they
all come out of the states
everything came from the states the
states was where
it was you know for wrestling yeah so it
was bigger than england and europe and
all that sort of stuff
so you guys like you know we're we're
doing it we got it we
if we want to make it big time we gotta
we gotta go to california
no we didn't come to california that was
for hollywood
and actors we just got two promoters
that the new zealand promoter uh knew
very well
that they were the vashon brothers
morris fair shawn mad dog vachon
he's dead now his brother they just put
another movie out about them
this weekend but um they were two
frenchmen
were well known throughout the states
and they owned a territory
in montreal called grand prix
so they bought us over there this this
territory was running
three times a night this promotion was
running they had a crew
this was a big a big promotion running
three times a night in in the province
of
ontario and quebec and and and northern
part
of um vermont
and a and upstate new york they'd come
into that
and that and it was out of montreal wow
and uh so we they brought us over there
and of course the main heel was walter
kowalski
and the main babyface a good guy was the
giant
so we we andre he just
andre andre just come to north america
the first time six months before we did
oh [ __ ] from and where was he living in
france
yes okay and he was working europe and
england
and he came in he came in a year six
months eight months before us
so when we come in he was over like hell
it was drawing this
these this this territory was on fire
yeah you know what i mean so
when we came in we knew the two main
guys
and um and after about a month
we were one of the main events in the
third town in one of the towns
and that you know what i mean we were
used we were used right
that hbo that hbo documentary on andre
was
insane yeah the stuff that he had to go
through
like everyday life flying in airplanes
how much of torture that was for him
oh yeah come to the people i got to tell
you about that later
on going to the pooper he could never
get oh yeah
anyhow we're not we're going back so
here i am
in this territory and um at the time too
pierre trudeau was the prime minister
his son is the prime minister now and
he's not so good like prime minister of
of canada canada yeah and he was going
out with mick jagg as his wife
bianca he was effing around with mick
jagger's wife it was
you know broken up with her but that was
a big thing at the time so his ex-wife
yeah and at the time too when we came
into
party quebecois was trying to break away
from canada
and be its own country it's crazy you
know the politics then
yeah quebec you know it was wild at the
time
you